ok beruhigt mich beruhigt nicht vom
runter servus skills und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ist es passiert am 28 juni hat der
primergy server probleme mit dem
korrekten gemeldet seit dem 28
juni ist der planet die server down und
die leute vom clementi sagen selbst dass
sie nichts daran ändern können dass der
server offline ist das heißt es bleibt
jetzt erstmal so offensichtlich sie
schreiben selbst wir können gar nichts
machen und was soll ich ohne job machen
aber leute es gibt es gibt ein licht
schirmer es gibt ein licht schirmer und
dieser lichtshow heißt trump auf
bergwerk labs und dem problem wie heute
aus das ist wie eine mischung aus jump
league und get down eigentlich das ganze
funktioniert so erkennt spielmodus
wahrscheinlich oder nicht glaubwürdig
erklärt das coole ist dadurch dass man
vor dem death match einem beifahrer hat
kann man sich im kit mit kaufen und kann
sich auch deutlich besseres equipment
kaufen erst mal dass in jump league
normalerweise bekommt zb irgendwie op
enchanted schwerter das ist alles
möglich und ihr prinz davon mag
wir fangen an mit dem easy modul obst
margot käßmann bekommt für seine jumping
skills in anführungszeichen oder nicht
punkte
je besser man springt desto mehr punkte
gibt zehn punkte mehr punkte man hat
desto mehr equipment kann man sich dann
am ende kaufen und es ist eigentlich
ganz leiste mischung aus den beiden
spielmodi wie gesagt und getan hat dann
habe ich selbst nie gespielt oder kaum
gespielt im blick
ein bisschen ja okay leute mein ganzes
leben bei dem blick nehmen very nice
wir probieren einfach unser glück und
guck mal wie wir mit diesem neuen
spielmodus zurechtkommen ich habe den
heute zum ersten mal gespielt vor einer
halben stunde oder so was heißt ihr habt
0 übung hier drin
die allermeisten modul habe ich noch nie
gesehen immer im leben und dabei zum
beispiel der erste job fehlen und es
geht das folgendermaßen habt quasi roten
kreuzes auftaucht und das telegramm
fällt sobald ihr die drei kreuze voll
hat und dann noch mal fällt kriegt ihr
hilfen das heißt das jump'n'run modul
verändert sich und wird leichter so abt
ist viel gesehen jetzt habe ich hier die
drei kreuze folgen haben leiter bekommen
weil ich mich gerade eben einfach nicht
konzentriert beim reden und reden da
springen springen zu springen
jetzt haben wir überall leidenschaft
auch der schlechte risiken julien
sprunger wir gucken mal wie das so
weitergeht
ich will die kreuze nicht alle kommt was
nicht einfach hier verband gehe mir mein
herz zurück die post meine liebe nicht
was man das gerade jetzt kommt kann man
das irgendwie der bildschirm kann man
sehr heiß
einfach augen zu und durch
das war richtig dass gerade in gut hier
kommen sie da beamten mit den drei
blöcken das sind doch kein thema das ist
jetzt natürlich ein bisschen tricky
vielleicht sogar bis neun tage laufen
und das ist wieder in
david fall von zack zack zack damit der
module abgeschlossen und ich gehe mal
davon aus dass man je mehr jump one hat
deswegen punkte bekommt man war zwar
kein deutscher satz leute aber ja okay
zum beispiel der leiter kassiert es kann
nicht sein
es kann nicht sein wo kommen die ganzen
leider niemand will die leitern ich will
einfach nur versucht schaffen
doch herr dauert ok als modul 10
wackelpudding extreme okay dass ein
eisberg war mein fehler macht da einfach
keine ahnung irgend etwas unsichtbares
raus slams
negative hinaus für das lenken okay man
muss einfach warten bis der block sich
quasi abkühlt dann in anspruch nehmen
und jetzt sind wir aber im deathmatch
wir haben 2000 50 points leute bzw
wir sind nicht in das match sondern sind
erstmal der bei fans und die ganze
erstmal kurz sie alle da so sieht das
aus interessierte können wir ganz
klassisch die alten rüstung das ist
natürlich über training rein damit dann
selbstverständlich auch ein eisen
schwert und jetzt 850 uns genau
überlegen was will man machen
angel ist noch wichtig und mit dem rest
kaufen wir unsere gold apfel bis den
fuso und jetzt klopfen wir einfach zu
sauer weggefährte drauf dass die
entscheidungswege teurer gut informiert
wieder top leute wir sind im live
matches ganze sieht so aus hier und wir
haben wie gesagt dass ein schwert das
ist nicht schlecht aber ich hatte auch
schon mal heute in einer runde davor ich
hab jetzt damit 200 euro damit gespielt
mannschaft 13
das ist deutlich gar den am netz wird
ganz gut erwischt würde ich sagen soll
ich da sein er wollte dass wir bei einer
zeit wo man kann unter anderem wenn man
ordentliche jumps verlegt wirklich
sauberen link sack den keller
und wie sowie den sie bekommen dann
unfair ja genau wo man kann nicht
gewonnen
das ist doch nett da freuen sich alle 14
klatschen den haben sowie thomas singer
zack den haben wir auch sehr schön
ok als der ist direkt rausgeflogen
selbst gesehen wenn ihr so jemand gilt
als das fleisch mich einfach mal kurz in
gold ab und dann
ihr macht michelle can bring mich ja
lauter musik combo bis ins internet ist
ja auch raus ist sehr schön essen kriegt
aber man kam eine generation tue und das
sollte reichen um den hier auf einem
server lag saftige gesehen ja noch
einmal zugeben rolle des aufbaus und ja
läuft soweit 0 des soweit einige kills
teil der dachfläche vor dem aufstellen
der macht richten kann so la la la la la
la la displays oder unten junge das war
richtig groß wie man sich massiv
erschwert hatte generell ok weisen 1
lohnt sich noch mal zu gucken was ich
alles dafür tut mit truppen seiner
schärfe schäfer 10 schärfe 4
kein wunder da ist so viel schaden
gemacht wahrscheinlich hatte der
beschäftigten gut so etwas einfach noch
der letzte gegner ist und dann sind wir
soweit ganz gut durch die erste
fairtrade abgekommen und seine leute ich
hab mich an unten
stopp halt stopp sie fragen warum es ist
mein haus ich will einfach geistig drei
jahre halten und es bleibt so wie sie
einfach weg besser als irgendwas sagen
michael das ist mein haushalt oder wieso
willst widersprechen
pikant ist scheinbar überhaupt nicht
denkt sie aber sowas dass wir eigentlich
stört haben motherfucker gebe ich an der
runde bin okay jetzt red i und let's go
können sie teilhaben können wir perfekt
und wir haben 90 runde gespielt das ist
in ordnung okay leute das war's soweit
von der ersten runde 43 gefallen hat mir
vielleicht mehr zu sehen wollt so lange
gesperrt ist und der server einfach
untergegangen ist vorüber
darin schreibt kommentare ansonsten